[Music]
in Karma's a [ __ ] news oh yeah
submitted by mother nature mother nature
a politician who opposes mandatory
chickenpox vaccinations got chickenpox
never got chickenpox vaccinated that's
hilarious
out of this whole life you get a chance
to get chickenpox and it had to be when
he was in the public eye being like you
shouldn't get vaccinated yeah and then
he gets a right after in his face feel
like everyone should just get chickenpox
like early there's some controversy
about that because some people just do
that if a kid gets chickenpox then they
take their kids and they'll have a
chicken pox party yeah but isn't that I
just I'm just bitter because I had to go
through it and it was itchy as [ __ ] and
I already had eczema it was like itchy
itchy
well they say like if you get it when
you're a kid it's better than when
you're an adult like it's not as painful
yeah yeah cuz when it's when it's an
adult's another thing right it's called
shingles you can still get shingles I
play good shingles damn diseases they
got a makeup in my man what do you want
to do
shingles are supposed to be really
[ __ ] people yeah and then chickenpox
as an adult can be deadly
yeah what did you have yeah psoriasis I
thought I had psoriasis well is that so
the first doc that I went to said I had
psoriasis but it turned out to be
shingles no no no no it was oh it was
[ __ ] bedbugs reaction to bed bugs no
it was just I got [ __ ] bit up so so
the so what happens
so psoriasis like event blast arises
like I guess like a very common place
where it starts it's actually at the
middle of your stomach here and this is
where I got bit the [ __ ] up so it looked
like psoriasis and then there was more
popping up but it was just from the bed
blood you figure out your doctor was
wrong huh how did you figure out your
doctor was right another because he has
two teeth here and no well and when I
had it so one of Muriel's friends has
psoriasis and she said to me it didn't
look like it and so I got a little
skeptic so and I've been going to the
hospital more frequently just because
why not I'm a little older so I've just
been a little more careful
but I also learn that you should get a
second opinion on stuff so I got a
second opinion and the person was like
that's not surprising they're like
that's something else it might be better
just wait for it to chill out and if it
starts growing more than the psoriasis
if it's not into something else and it
turned out to be big but you just got to
wait you got to put [ __ ] creams and
[ __ ] and insurance I had a [ __ ] clean
everything out bedbugs are not firm buy
throw away all the sheets I threw
everything else away you have to
basically get rid of everything rather
get bit by a hundred mosquitoes then
like a lot of bedbugs Wow bedbug bites
her way more than mosquito bites and I
found the book - it was just one yeah by
the time you see one that means there's
thousands I don't know I saw one and I
[ __ ] just did that [ __ ] doodoo
mattress good whatever that [ __ ] is I
know there was like a spray I bought an
Amazon is shared and I did all that
stuff but they said that if you've I
forgot what I was reading it but if you
catch it early or something like that
because it was just one day and then it
was like a couple days or some like that
so I remember I found out that I went
camping and then it came back and then I
went to get my [ __ ] check to the
doctor's and he goes that's not
psoriasis I got bit up by the sub egg
bugs in Texas and University Austin and
then one stowed away on my suitcase and
still crawled in everyday I was getting
like different bedbug bites and I was
like [ __ ] and one day I found that
[ __ ] killed him and it does it oh so
just one day just one but the pain from
a bedbug it's like imagine you get the
itchiness of a mosquito but there's like
yeah where the bite is it's like a real
sharp pain ah oh and then also on top of
that I forgot what I had I was having
like an allergic reaction to something
so where the bed bug bit me
I was also it was also inflamed because
my skin was inflamed from some kind of
allergic reaction Oh - cocoa butter so
that's why you couldn't see the actual
bug bite yeah you're allergic today is
that how you found out you were allergic
whatever whatever's in Palmer's if it's
just cocoa butter something else in
there I can't use Palmer's cocoa butter
because I was using that because because
of the loose skin that I was getting
from losing weight or trying to tighten
it up yeah which it does work so I used
something else and it tightened it up
but then like it was
as I was losing I was putting it on but
I found out that whatever's in Palmer's
cocoa butter I'm allergic to huh do you
still use Palmer's anytime you put on a
smell like a chocolate dessert I love
the smell of that heats it what I want
her to be sexy I want or smell like a
chocolate cake you want to smell like
more fruity yeah
because Mary almost the Palmer [ __ ] too
so she uses it I love that [ __ ] do you
want me to smell sexier feel sexy both
the app powers is [ __ ] the let's go
with let's go with fine have you ever
tried hemp's lotion no I switched to
that like I used to use Palmer's all the
time
I switched that I don't know if it does
the same thing as stretch marks but it
made my skin the same amount of softness
and it's made out of hemp oil or
something and it's been around for a
long time but it's like this really good
lotion and it doesn't smell like a
chocolate cake it smells like a like a
sweet plant
what about mango shea butter that one's
pretty good too what about that there it
is conversation done let's go no I have
different ones because I know he's a
picky
all the time you know I gotta give him
what he wants sometimes mom yes this
story is about this Italian politician
dude oh the story with us about it no it
didn't you know Barney July marsalano
melech Rica but I Kiko look at the
cheetah cheetah cheetah Pellegrino
parmigiana
can somebody yeah so he was leading an
anti vaccination legislation nobody
needs a chicken a boxer look at the key
look if he just got all 20 diseases I
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
joke so this legislation that he was
opposing it was to make vaccinations for
ten diseases mandatory for all children
going to school or less or else they
won't be allowed to attend shoot so he
was saying that he didn't like that he
didn't like how you have to force
children to get vaccinated I've got
people to be forced before they travel
and turn big being a hospital the
military we don't want people if I can
get mixed up with all that [ __ ] is he a
conspiracy theorist well no so the
[ __ ] Illuminati is coming in so he
claims that he isn't anti vex because he
had his own children vaccinated so is
the hypocrite that's pretty cool whoa
okay I guess that's endangering other
people's lives yeah that's why because
that kind of makes sense in a school
setting or a hospital or anything else
where it's like yeah but he was against
forcing people like is he against
forcing people not to carry bombs on
planes you know yeah it's like the same
kind of [ __ ] it's like you're
endangering a choice being able to
choose if they want their bomb on their
plane with them well would it be would
it be just the people that aren't
vaccinated are in danger yeah mm-hmm and
people with low immune like if you have
an autoimmune disease and you can't get
vaccinated there's ah there's a lot of
people that can't get vaccinated and so
they're more susceptible to diseases and
then if you are just a turkey or if
you're an adult like him and who's never
had chickenpox you know one of your
students kids has it whatever I don't
know yeah and then he gets chickenpox
then he gets too shiny got chickenpox
and so he was in the hospital but then
he was like oh I'm at home now did you
take back his position freedom of choice
yeah he thought this was my choice a
choice is cool because of that
eradicated are bad because of the anti
vaccine mmm thanks a lot for that you
[ __ ] faces here's my conspiracy the
disease crawled into their brain and
then they're like we need to come back
like a parasite I think I found a host
we need to come back and they're like
they control the mind of hippies and
they're like yeah we'll need [ __ ]
vaccines for children they got nature
it's like you know that guy was a CEO of
a huge financial corporation two weeks
ago they got him the disease got him
yeah you could not vaccinate your kids
just don't have them play around mine
yeah yeah I mean [ __ ] little Sally
smallpox and Peter Paul here about
freaking God at the busines lion no
because they contracted or something at
the Disneyland and they were anti
vaccine yeah I don't they all died we
backed the [ __ ] outta Tiger deal yeah
you call healthy he is dude mmm-hmm yeah
Charlie Sheen's anti vaccine you have
like seven different forms of AIDS
[Laughter]
Rob Schneider yeah Jenny McCarthy that's
because she says her kid got autism from
FX
yeah that's not true Alicia Silverstone
and Andrew Wakefield to turn on what it
is but I mean like I don't take life
advice from celebrities they're just
great [ __ ] actors you know
like that was the weird thing like hi
I'm Alicia Silverstone's yeah it's like
I I'm gonna take advice from a scientist
I don't care what deuce Bigalow is
anti-vaxxer like okay that's awesome
yeah
already did or what if they know some
[ __ ] that we don't like because they're
around the rich and powerful and in
there getting some secrets that we don't
know and all of them would be doing it
yeah that's true yeah yeah I don't know
these are just the people that are out
maybe there's a lot more celebrities
that just are like don't tell the poor I
don't know I'm trying to I'm just trying
to back to the [ __ ] out of my dogs to
deworm the [ __ ] out of them cuz they
were drinking all kinds of [ __ ] water
yeah well like I teen.com I don't
[ __ ] drink that [ __ ] I'm like thank
God I have dirty [ __ ] worm medicine
[ __ ] parasites dying in them mm-hmm
but would imagine all the kids think
it's some [ __ ] of parasites and all
kinds of nasty [ __ ]
[Music]